Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK...
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESSES.
Together: INTRODUCING
THE SIMPLY FIT BOARD.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
OH, MY GOD.
I LOVE THAT.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000 FOR 30%.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
NOW, BARBARA,
I'M COUNTING ON YOU.
JUST BEFORE
YOU START PITCHING HER,
I'M GONNA TELL YOU,
SHE'S REALLY BAD WITH NUMBERS.
-KEVIN, THAT'S SO RIDICULOUS.
-HE'S SO RUDE.
I'M NOT RUDE.
Narrator:
THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
THEY WILL BET
ON WHO WE ARE.
KUMBAYA. WHO CARES?
DO YOU HAVE DEBT
ON THE COMPANY?
$130K.
OKAY, YOUR COMPANY
HAS CURRENTLY NO VALUE AT ALL.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE BUSINESS
EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE SELLING
A CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
SON OF AN IMMIGRANT
FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF THE WORLD'S
PREEMINENT CYBERSECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS,
AND HAS LAUNCHED MORE
THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE,
TECH MOGUL,
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS
A GUILT-FREE VERSION
OF A FAVORITE TREAT.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS GABE WOLFF.
I'M ANI BLINOVA, AND WE'RE
FROM STAMFORD, CONNECTICUT.
OUR COMPANY
IS WINK FROZEN DESSERTS,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $300,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
ICE CREAM -- IT'S A M--
IT'S -- I --
-YES, IT IS.
-IT IS.
EASY TO SAY.
ICE CREAM -- IT'S AMERICA'S
FAVORITE DESSERT,
BUT LET'S FACE IT --
IT'S SO BAD FOR YOU.
BUT GOING COLD TURKEY
ON THIS FROZEN TREAT
IS A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
THAN IT SOUNDS.
AS AN ICE CREAM ADDICT MYSELF
WHO'S VERY HEALTH-CONSCIOUS,
I DECIDED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT,
SO I WENT INTO THE KITCHEN
AND PLAYED MAD SCIENTIST
TO CREATE MY OWN HEALTHY,
ALL-NATURAL FROZEN TREAT.
WINK FROZEN DESSERTS
IS A DAIRY-FREE
AND SUGAR-FREE FROZEN TREAT
THAT'S NOT ONLY VEGAN --
IT'S FREE OF ALL
THE TOP 8 ALLERGENS
AND, MY PERSONAL
FAVORITE PART,
WEIGHS IN
AT ONLY 100 CALORIES...
Together:
FOR THE ENTIRE PINT!
MOST IMPORTANTLY,
WE DO ALL THIS BY USING...
WHAT?!
...NATURAL, NON-GENETICALLY
MODIFIED INGREDIENTS
WHILE STILL DELIVERING
ON SWEETNESS AND FLAVOR.
SHARKS, WITH WINK, YOU WON'T
EVEN MISS REGULAR ICE CREAM.
WE'VE CREATED
A DELICIOUS TREAT
THAT SATISFIES
ALMOST ANY SWEET TOOTH,
BUT NEED YOUR HELP
IN ORDER
TO BRING WINK
TO THE NATIONAL STAGE.
SO, SHARKS, NOW IT'S YOUR TURN
TO TRY THE HEALTHIEST...
AND TASTIEST.
...THING TO EVER HAPPEN
TO ICE CREAM.
Together: WINK!
-CAN WE TRY IT?
-OF COURSE.
-ABSOLUTELY.
-GABE, I HAVE BAD NEWS FOR YOU.
-YEAH?
-I AM AN ICE CREAM EXPERT.
-UH-OH.
NOBODY EATS MORE
ICE CREAM THAN ME.
I LOVE THE STUFF.
Blinova: WELL,
IT'S DEFINITELY DIFFERENT.
WE'VE INDIVIDUALIZED
EACH SUNDAE IN THE MIDDLE.
OH, THANK YOU.
IT'S VANILLA WITH MAPLE PECAN
GRANOLA AND SOME CHERRIES.
WOW, WE'RE IN
FOR SOME GOOD STUFF.
LORI, THIS IS FOR YOU.
IT IS OUR CAKE BATTER,
MY PERSONAL FAVORITE FLAVOR...
-THANK YOU.
-...WITH STRAWBERRIES
AND DAIRY-FREE AND ALLERGEN-FREE
CHOCOLATE CHIPS.
Wolff:
IN THE MIDDLE IS THE SUNDAE,
AND RIGHT ON THE PERIMETER
OF YOUR SUNDAE,
YOU HAVE A SAMPLE
OF EACH FLAVOR.
SO WE HAVE SIX FLAVORS.
OUR FIRST FLAVOR
IS CAKE BATTER.
IT'S A GLUTEN-FREE
CAKE BATTER,
SO THERE IS NO OTHER GLUTEN-FREE
CAKE BATTER ON THE MARKET YET.
THEN WE HAVE COCOA DOUGH,
WHICH IS LIKE
A CHOCOLATY COOKIE DOUGH.
THEN WE DO CINNAMON BUN,
ICED LATTE,
AND CHOCO-MINT,
AND THEN VANILLA BEAN.
WHAT IS
THE SUBSTITUTE SUGAR?
WE USE ORGANIC STEVIA
AND MONK FRUIT TO SWEETEN IT.
IT TASTES KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
IN THE MIDDLE.
MM-HMM.
THAT'S WHY WE DO THE SUNDAES,
TO ADD A LITTLE BIT
OF FLAVOR TO IT AND SO
YOU CAN CUSTOMIZE IT.
I-I DIDN'T WANT TO SAY IT...
NO, THAT'S FINE.
YOU CAN SAY IT.
...BUT IT TASTES KIND OF BLAND
ON ITS OWN.
YEAH, IT'S NOT A PRODUCT
THAT'S MEANT TO HIT A HOME RUN
WITH EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO TRIES IT.
YEAH.
IS IT A PRODUCT THAT'S MEANT
TO BE EATEN ON ITS OWN,
OR DO YOU SEE IT
AS A MIXER WITH SOMETHING?
YEP.
WELL, WE HAVE CUSTOMERS
THAT DO BOTH.
I, PERSONALLY, LOVE TO EAT THE
CAKE BATTER ON -- ON ITS OWN.
O'Leary: BUT, ANI, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE 100 CALORIES.
YOU COULD BE 200 CALORIES
AND STILL BE 50% LESS
THAN MOST ICE CREAMS MADE
WITH MILK FAT.
IS THAT TRUE? IS THE AVERAGE TUB
OF THAT SIZE 500 CALORIES?
600 CALORIES.
-YEAH.
-SO, WOW!
SO DID YOU TEST GOING
TO 200 CALORIES TO SEE
IF IT -- IT MADE THE BASE
PRODUCT MORE INTERESTING?
SURE.
YEAH, AND WHAT IT DOES --
YOU GET MORE OF THE FLAVOR,
BUT YOU DO END UP
ADDING A COUPLE GRAMS OF FAT
OR LIKE 1 GRAM OF SUGAR.
WELL, WHAT DO SALES SAY?
I MEAN, IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT I PERSONALLY THINK.
YEAH, HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
-IT MATTERS WHAT SALES ARE.
-SO -- ABSOLUTELY.
SO, TO DATE,
WE'VE SOLD $534,000 WORTH.
-OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME?
-THREE YEARS, UM...
OHH.
AND HOW
DO YOU SELL IT?
WE STARTED WITH AN ONLINE STORE,
GOING DIRECT TO CONSUMER.
Blinova:
WE'RE IN SEVERAL RETAILERS
AROUND OUR AREA
IN THE NORTHEAST.
SO WE'RE IN WHOLE FOODS.
YOGURTS --
HOW MANY WHOLE FOODS
ARE YOU IN?
-30.
WHAT IS THE SUBSTANCE
THAT THIS IS MADE OUT OF?
SO, THE BASE IS PEA PROTEIN,
SO IT'S A VEGETABLE
PROTEIN-BASED NON-GMO.
PEA PROTEIN.
GABE, I WAS CURIOUS --
YOU WERE TELLING US YOUR STORY,
AND YOU SAID YOU
JUST WENT IN THE KITCHEN...
-YEAH.
-...AND MADE THE ICE CREAM.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
SO, GROWING UP,
I WAS THE CHUBBY KID IN SCHOOL.
YOU WERE?
YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD.
I GOT PICKED ON A LOT.
-THANK YOU.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-BARBARA, LEAVE HIM ALONE.
-YOU'D NEVER KNOW IT.
SO, MY WHOLE
ENTIRE FAMILY STRUGGLED
WITH DIABETES, WITH OBESITY.
AND THEN WHEN I TURNED 17,
I WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH CELIAC DISEASE
AND A DAIRY INTOLERANCE,
SO IT DRASTICALLY CHANGED
THE WAY I HAD TO EAT.
AND THIS IS A FULL-TIME JOB
FOR BOTH OF YOU?
-YES.
-NOW IT IS, YES.
-YEAH.
HOW MUCH DID YOU
MAKE LAST YEAR?
THE COMPANY
LOST MONEY LAST YEAR...
YEAH.
...BUT GROSS PROFIT
WAS ABOUT $87,000.
AND WHERE'S
THE BREAK-EVEN POINT?
WE'RE ACTUALLY PROJECTED
TO MAKE $650,000 THIS YEAR.
YEP.
WHY A SUDDEN CHANGE? IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S A BIG LEAP HERE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 180 STORES
THAT ARE COMING ON.
THE REASON THERE WAS
SUCH A LOSS LAST YEAR
WAS BECAUSE WE HAD PROBLEMS
WITH THE CO-PACKER.
WE HAD THEIR FREEZER
BREAKING DOWN.
WE LOST ABOUT $60,000
WORTH OF PRODUCT.
OUCH.
-OKAY, THAT'S WHY.
-RIGHT AT ICE CREAM SEASON.
LIKE, THE NUMBERS
JUST DIDN'T ADD UP --
I HAVE A QUESTION.
GUYS, I'M NOT CRAZY
ABOUT YOUR PRODUCT,
AND PERHAPS
I LACK APPRECIATION,
BUT I DIDN'T FIND
IT HAD ANY TASTE
UNTIL I BIT
INTO YOUR TRIMMINGS THERE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THAN THE TASTE, FOR ME,
I LOVE TO BUY A BUSINESS
THAT'S ON THE WINNING SIDE.
EVERYBODY LOVES A WINNER,
ESPECIALLY INVESTORS.
I THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN FAR
BETTER FOR YOU TO COME IN HERE
AFTER YOU'D TURNED THE CORNER
OF A PROFIT OF SOME KIND.
-SURE.
SO BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
OF YOUR PITCH, I'M OUT.
-OKAY, THANK VERY MUCH.
-THANK YOU.
I WOULD -- I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU VOICED.
FINE -- FOR THE OTHER SHARKS,
CERTAINLY.
SO, WE'RE GONNA MAKE
$650,000 THIS YEAR,
EASILY MAKING $450,000
IN THE SECOND HALF OF THIS YEAR.
AT THAT,
WE'LL MAKE A $50,000 PROFIT.
NEXT YEAR,
WE'VE ALREADY HAD MEETINGS
WITH SOME
OF THE BIGGER RETAILERS.
THEY LOVE THE PRODUCT.
THEY LOVE WHO WE ARE.
THEY LOVE WHAT WE'RE DOING.
GUYS, I WANTED SO BAD
TO LOVE THIS.
MM.
I'M LACTOSE INTOLERANT.
IF MY WIFE EVEN SEES ICE CREAM,
SHE YANKS IT AWAY
BECAUSE SHE HAS TO PAY THE
PENALTY OF ME EATING ICE CREAM.
RIGHT.
I'M SURE
IT'S AN ACQUIRED TASTE.
-MM-HMM.
-IT JUST WASN'T MY TASTE.
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
GABE, I LOVE HOW
YOU STARTED THE BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE A PASSION FOR IT.
YOU'RE GONNA KEEP GOING.
IN FOOD,
I GOT TO LOVE THE PRODUCT.
I WISH YOU ALL THE SUCCESS
IN THE WORLD, UM...
BUT I'M OUT.
OKAY.
UM, 100 CALORIES
FOR A PINT...
-YEAH.
-I MEAN, WHAT PERSON
DOESN'T WANT TO EAT
A PINT OF ICE CREAM?
-EXACTLY.
-THE PROBLEM FOR ME IS --
IS I DIDN'T REALLY LOVE
THE TASTE OF IT.
I REALLY WANTED TO,
BUT I'M OUT.
SO, WE'RE ALL OUT
EXCEPT KEVIN.
WELL, I'M LISTENING
TO THE OTHER SHARKS,
AND -- AND, BASICALLY,
WHAT THEY'VE SAID,
AND INTERPRETING IT DOWN
TO WHAT THEY MEAN IS THIS --
YOU'VE ACHIEVED VEGAN,
GLUTEN FREE, SUGAR FREE,
DAIRY FREE, SOY FREE, FAT FREE,
NUT FREE, EGG FREE,
AND TASTE FREE.
THE ONLY CUSTOMERS
YOU HAVE ARE ONES
THAT HAVE TO HAVE THIS
FOR HEALTH REASONS.
I GET IT,
BUT I THINK YOU CAN DO BETTER.
I THINK THIS PRODUCT
COULD HAVE MET AT LEAST HALFWAY
THE EXPECTATIONS
OF A CUBAN, OR LORI,
WHO'S SO POLITE
IN THE WAY SHE SAYS
IT TASTES LIKE CRAP,
BUT IT DOES TASTE LIKE CRAP --
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
AND MAYBE THAT'S THE WAY
IT HAS TO TASTE,
BUT AS AN INVESTMENT,
NOT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
-OKAY.
-HE'S SO RUDE.
-I'M NOT RUDE.
-OH, YES, YOU'RE RUDE.
Cuban:
HEY, GUYS, BEFORE YOU FREAK OUT
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING, RIGHT,
'CAUSE OBVIOUSLY, IT'S NOT WHAT
YOU EXPECT TO COME IN HERE.
RIGHT.
DIFFERENT PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
TASTES, SO I DON'T WANT TO --
YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO THROW YOU UNDER THE BUS.
WELL, GABE, YOU'RE NOT GOING
AFTER A WIDE MARKET.
SURE.
IT'S BETTER TO BE THE BEST WINK
IN A NARROW CATEGORY.
I-I UNDERSTAND, LIKE,
IT'S NOT WHAT YOU GUYS EXPECTED.
YEAH, IT'S NOT
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
BUT, I MEAN, OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE OBSESSED WITH US.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
-DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR YOU.
-THANK YOU.
♪♪
WE'RE SUPER DISAPPOINTED
THAT THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT.
WE REALLY WANTED THEM
TO ENJOY THE PRODUCT.
WE REALLY COULD USE
THE MONEY RIGHT NOW
AND REALLY STEP ON THE GAS,
BUT I GUESS WE'LL JUST HAVE TO
CONTINUE GRINDING IT OUT.
♪♪
-I'M DEBRA.
-I AM HUGO.
Debra: AND OUR COMPANY
IS SAAVY NATURALS.
YOU READY TO COOK?
HUGO AND I MET
ALMOST 30 YEARS AGO.
Hugo: SHE FILLED MY HEART
WITH LOVE,
AND I KNEW
THAT SHE WAS MY SOUL MATE.
[ SIZZLING ]
DON'T THEY LOOK GOOD?
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL.
DELICIOUS.
OUR BACKGROUND
IS IN THE FOOD BUSINESS.
WE ARE
PROFESSIONAL CHEFS.
-CAN I TASTE IT?
-TASTE IT.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT WE PUT
IN OUR BODIES IS IMPORTANT,
BUT IT'S WHAT WE PUT
ON OUR SKIN, AS WELL.
USING OUR CULINARY SKILLS,
WE SET OUT TO MAKE
THE MOST NATURAL
BEAUTY CARE PRODUCTS EVER.
-WHAT A GENIUS.
-OH. [ CHUCKLES ]
THIS ISN'T
OUR FIRST COMPANY.
WE HAD A COMPANY THAT WE BUILT
TO $10 MILLION IN SALES.
WE SOLD TOO MUCH
OF OUR EQUITY.
WE LOST MAJORITY OWNERSHIP
OF THAT BUSINESS,
AND WE REALLY SEE SAAVY
AS OUR SECOND CHANCE AT SUCCESS.
WE NEED THE BUSINESS SAVVY
OF A SHARK
TO HELP US
SHARE OUR PASSION
OF FOOD AND BEAUTY CARE
WITH THE WORLD.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DEBRA SAAVEDRA.
AND MY NAME
IS HUGO SAAVEDRA.
WE ARE THE FOUNDERS
OF SAAVY NATURALS.
WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO ASK FOR $200,000
FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING, SHARKS --
ANOTHER LINE OF SOAPS
AND LOTION.
THIS LINE IS DIFFERENT
THAN ANYTHING
THE WORLD HAS EVER SEEN
OR TASTED BEFORE.
AND I SAY "TASTED."
IT'S SO INCREDIBLE
THAT YOU CAN EAT IT --
SO PURE THAT
YOU CAN FEED YOUR WIFE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-MMM, DELICIOUS.
-[ LAUGHS ]
SHARKS, DID YOU KNOW YOUR SKIN
IS YOUR BODY'S LARGEST ORGAN?
OUR PHILOSOPHY IS
THAT IF YOU CARE ABOUT
WHAT YOU PUT IN YOUR BODY,
YOU SHOULD ALSO CARE ABOUT
WHAT YOU PUT ON YOUR BODY.
THAT'S WHY
WE CREATED SAAVY NATURALS.
THE REASON WE PUT EMPHASIS
IN ABOUT THE FOOD, WE ARE CHEFS.
EVERY SINGLE PRODUCT HERE --
THE WHOLE ENTIRE LINE --
IS MADE WITH FOOD-GRADE
INGREDIENTS.
AND WE MAKE
EVERY SINGLE PRODUCT
IN OUR VERY OWN
KITCHEN FACTORY
TO ENSURE
THE HIGHEST INTEGRITY.
SO, SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO JOIN US
AND HELP US TO MAKE
THE WORLD --
THE WORLD
A MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACE?
CAN WE SEE IT?
CAN WE TRY IT?
SURE.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE SOME SAMPLES FOR YOU.
-IT SMELLS EXTREMELY FRAGRANT.
-YEAH.
CAN BARBARA TASTE IT FIRST?
-YES, SURE.
-[ CHUCKLES ] I'M WILLING.
IF YOU DON'T SURVIVE, BARBARA,
I'LL MAKE KEVIN TRY IT NEXT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S REALLY DELICIOUS.
Greiner: OH, I'M SURE.
WE'RE GETTING SOME?
IS IT, BARBARA?
-AND I'M GONNA --
-WHAT ARE YOU -- [ LAUGHS ]
-UH-OH.
-BARB, DID YOU LIKE IT?
IT'S NOT BAD. IT TASTES
LIKE PERFUME AND SUGAR.
-YOU KNOW WHAT?
-THANK YOU.
WOW, THIS SMELLS GREAT.
WHAT IS THIS?
THAT IS A TAHITIAN VANILLA
AND KUKUI.
-THE REASON IS --
-WHAT DO YOU DO WITH IT?
IT'S A SCRUB --
EXFOLIATE.
IT WILL DETOXIFY YOUR SKIN,
REJUVENATE YOUR SKIN.
AND OUR PHILOSOPHY IS THAT
WHAT YOU PUT ON YOUR SKIN
SHOULD BE AS PURE AS THE FOOD
THAT YOU EAT AND THAT --
IT'S NOT THAT YOU EXPECT
ANYBODY TO EAT IT.
RIGHT, IT'S NOT --
...YOU JUST DON'T WANT
CHEMICALS IN IT.
EXACTLY. THANK YOU, LORI.
IT'S --
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE HAD AROUND,
IN THE PAST YEAR, $750,000.
GOOD FOR YOU.
-WOW, WAS IT ALL ONLINE?
-WOW, WHERE DO YOU SELL?
WE DON'T DO NO BUSINESS ONLINE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY.
-ARE YOU GONNA CHANGE THAT?
-YES.
WE WOULD LOVE TO CHANGE THAT.
-WE WILL.
-IT'S LOW-HANGING FRUIT.
-OKAY.
WHAT HAPPENED IS,
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN BUILDING
A BIG COMPANY.
WE GREW ALMOST
A $10 MILLION COMPANY --
A PREVIOUS COMPANY.
-OH, PREVIOUS.
WHAT -- WHAT DID
THAT COMPANY DO, HUGO?
THEY WERE DOING
SOAPS, LOTION.
OH, SO THIS --
YOU'VE DONE THIS BEFORE?
-WE DID. EXACTLY.
-EXACTLY.
WAS IT YOUR COMPANY, OR DID
YOU WORK FOR SOMEBODY ELSE?
Debra: IT WAS -- IT WAS
OUR COMPANY TO BEGIN WITH,
BUT WE LOST CONTROLLING
INTEREST IN THE COMPANY.
DEBRA, YOU BUILT
A $10 MILLION COMPANY
THAT YOU STARTED
AND YOU LOST CONTROL.
HOW DID YOU LOSE CONTROL?
[ SIGHS ]
WE BROUGHT IN INVESTORS,
AND WE SOLD THAT MAJORITY
INTEREST IN OUR COMPANY.
MAJORITY?
YOU MUST HAVE HAD A REASON
FOR DOING THAT THEN.
AND WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW?
I'M TELLING YOU WHAT,
WE WERE NOT SAVVY THEN,
BUT WE ARE "SAAVY" NOW.
WAS IT BECAUSE
YOU NEEDED CASH TO OPERATE?
-CORRECT.
GOT IT. AND THAT'S WHY
YOU LOST CONTROL?
-CORRECT.
-DID YOU JUST START THIS?
WE STARTED THIS
APPROXIMATELY A YEAR AGO.
DEBRA --
AND TWO MONTHS LATER,
WE WENT TO WHOLE FOODS.
Herjavec:
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
WE HAVE INCREDIBLE RELATIONS
IN OUR INDUSTRY --
THE NATURAL PRODUCT
INDUSTRY.
WE ARE --
SO $750,000 IN SALES
IS GOING THROUGH RETAIL?
-CORRECT.
-WHOLESALE TO WHOLE FOODS.
SO ARE YOU
IN WHOLE FOODS NATIONWIDE?
LET ME --
-NOT YET.
-NO.
WE CAN --
-WHAT REGION ARE YOU IN?
WE ARE IN A STORE
IN CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, BOSTON.
SO LET'S TAKE A TYPICAL PRODUCT
LIKE A BAR OF SOAP
AND WALK US
THROUGH THE NUMBERS.
SO, OUR PRODUCTS RANGE IN PRICE
FROM APPROXIMATELY $6 TO $15.
AND WHAT'S YOUR MARGIN
FROM WHOLESALE?
RIGHT NOW,
IT'S BETWEEN 30% AND 40%...
WE --
OOH.
...BECAUSE WE ARE BUYING
IN SUCH LIMITED QUANTITIES.
YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
FOR INVENTORY, BASICALLY?
EXACTLY.
CORRECT.
SO HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU PUT IN
TO START THE BUSINESS?
AROUND $350,000.
I JUST WANT TO BRING A LITTLE
REALITY TO OUR CONVERSATION,
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO DO IT AT THIS POINT.
THIS IS SOAP, OKAY?
THIS IS A COMMODITY,
AND IT'S VERY GOOD.
TELL ME WHERE I'M WRONG.
$200,000 FOR 10% COMPUTES
A VALUE OF $2 MILLION
FOR THIS BUSINESS.
CORRECT.
YOU MAKE $100,000 PRE-TAX,
OKAY?
YOU'RE GONNA PAY 25% TAX MINIMUM
ON THIS THING.
THAT MEANS 75%.
YOU WANT ME TO PAY
A 25 MULTIPLE ON SOAP?
YOU MUST BE KIDDING.
KEVIN, THAT'S SO RIDICULOUS.
THEY'RE JUST STARTING OUT.
IT'S NOT RIDICULOUS.
IT'S SOAP!
IT'S A FIRST-YEAR STARTUP.
-I -- I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT.
-I PREDICT WITH 100% CERTAINTY
YOU WILL NOT GET ONE SHARK
TO GIVE YOU $200,000 FOR 10%.
IF THEY WERE TO DO THAT,
THEY WOULDN'T BE A SHARK --
THEY'D BE BANKRUPT.
NO, BECAUSE THEY WILL BET
ON WHO WE ARE.
KUMBAYA. WHO CARES?
I'M SORRY, BUT --
IT'S CASH FLOW.
IT'S A COMMODITY.
CORRECT, BUT IN -- IN AUGUST,
WE'RE GONNA LAUNCH WITH ULTA.
-MR. WONDERFUL?
-YES.
BEFORE YOU -- YOU TELL ME
I AM A ROACH, I AM GONNA --
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M GONNA --
I AM GONNA TELL YOU WHAT.
MR. WONDERFUL.
Herjavec: I LOVE YOU.
I DIDN'T SAY YOU'RE A COCKROACH
IN THE SOAP BUSINESS,
I SAID YOU'RE INSANE
ON YOUR VALUATION.
NO, I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT BEFORE YOU DO THAT --
WE ARE NOT A ROACH,
BUT WE ARE LIKE
A BUTTERFLY AND A BEE.
MY WIFE IS
SO BEAUTIFUL, LUXURIOUS,
AND -- AND IS MY PARTNER
IN LIFE.
HOW MANY YEARS
HAVE YOU BEEN MARRIED?
10 YEARS.
WE FIRST MET 27 YEARS AGO.
WE MARRIED OTHER PEOPLE.
OUR LIVES WENT
IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
ONE DAY,
OUT OF THE COMPLETE BLUE,
I GET A PHONE CALL
FROM HIM.
17 YEARS LATER,
AND HE TOLD ME,
"I NEVER STOPPED
THINKING ABOUT YOU."
-OH, MY GOD, I LOVE THAT.
-WOW, DESTINY.
-KARMA.
-YOU GOT GAME, HUGO.
-YOU GOT GAME!
-OH, HONEY, LET ME TELL YA.
HE WON YOU OVER
BECAUSE HE WAS SO IN LOVE.
I LOVE THE STORY.
BUT THANK GOODNESS I'M HERE
TO BRING US BACK TO REALITY.
HUGO, YOU CAN'T GET
25 TIMES FOR SOAP.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
-YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
PEOPLE FALL IN LOVE
WITH OUR SOAP.
GOT IT.
I THINK THE PRODUCT'S GREAT.
BUT, DEBRA...
MY COUSIN TOLD ME
HE NEVER PAID ATTENTION
...IT'S SOAP.
TO A SOAP,
AND OURS IS SOAP CRACK.
IT'S SOAP!
IT THINK YOU'RE ONLY WORTH
ABOUT $400,000.
YOU HAVE DEBT
ON THE COMPANY NOW?
WE TOOK ON SOME DEBT
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
AROUND $400,000.
-UH-OH.
-YOU GOT GOOD FRIENDS.
OOH.
OKAY, YOUR COMPANY HAS CURRENTLY
NO VALUE AT ALL.
YOU -- YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE $400,000
OFF THE $400,000 VALUE
I GAVE YOU.
WELL,
WE'RE HERE TO NEGOTIATE.
I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU.
Cuban: GUYS, LOOK --
ONE OF MY COMPANIES
IS SIMPLE SUGARS,
AND SIMPLE SUGARS IS THE --
IS ALSO ONLY ORGANIC MATERIALS,
ONLY EDIBLE MATERIALS.
-I AM FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
-RIGHT.
Hugo: CORRECT.
BECAUSE IT'S COMPETITIVE
WITH SIMPLE SUGARS,
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SAY
I'M OUT.
-BUT WE --
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-THANK YOU.
-BUT --
I LOVE YOUR STORY.
I THINK YOU'RE A GREAT COUPLE.
I'M A ROMANTIC,
BUT MY THOUGHT --
IT'S A VERY COMPETITIVE SPACE.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS,
YOU GUYS HAVE EACH OTHER,
SO YOUR LIFE IS GOLDEN.
THEY STILL HAVE
TO PAY THEIR RENT, BABY.
-THANK YOU.
-I'M OUT.
BARBARA --
I'M COUNTING ON YOU.
JUST BEFORE
YOU START PITCHING HER,
I'M GONNA TELL YOU YOU HAVE
A LARGE CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
SHE'S REALLY BAD WITH NUMBERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Corcoran: BUT I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT I'M REALLY GREAT WITH.
I'M GREAT WITH PEOPLE.
AND YOU'RE JUST THE KIND
OF PEOPLE THAT I LOVE.
YOU'RE GENUINE.
YOUR HEART AND SOUL
IS TOTALLY INTO IT.
IF I SAID TO YOU, "I WANT YOU TO
CHANGE THE NAME OF THE BUSINESS.
HERE'S MY NAME.
IT'LL SELL BETTER."
HOW OPEN WOULD YOU BE?
-WE'D DO IT IN A HEARTBEAT.
SO YOU WOULD ACTUALLY LISTEN
TO SOMEONE FROM THE OUTSIDE,
KNOWING NOTHING
ABOUT YOUR INDUSTRY?
YOU WOULD BE TOTALLY OPEN
TO THAT?
THE THING THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO COMPROMISE ON
IS THE QUALITY
OF OUR PRODUCTS.
I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH KEVIN
ON THE VALUATION.
WHAT IF I SAID TO YOU,
"I'LL TAKE 50%
OF YOUR BUSINESS FOR $200,000"?
♪♪
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA IS INTERESTED
IN HUGO AND DEBRA'S
NATURAL BODY CARE LINE, SAAVY,
BUT SHE WANTS 50%
OF THE COMPANY.
UNDERSTAND SOMETHING --
YOU HAVE $400,000 OF DEBT.
THERE'S PRACTICALLY NOTHING
OF VALUE RIGHT NOW.
SHE'S GONNA STEP
IN FRONT OF THAT DEBT.
SHE'S GONNA HELP YOU
RUN THIS COMPANY.
Corcoran: I COULD HELP YOU
RUN THIS COMPANY,
BECAUSE I'M THE OPPOSITE
OF YOU, ALL RIGHT?
AND THOSE ARE
GREAT PARTNERSHIPS.
♪♪
I WOULD COUNTER FOR AT LEAST
A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN THAT
SO WE COULD RETAIN
MAJORITY.
MM-HMM.
I'M OUT.
WELL, WE WANT
A SUCCESSFUL COMPANY.
WE WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
WE WANT TO HAVE
A PROFITABLE COMPANY.
SHE SAID SHE'S OUT.
LOOK AT JESSICA ALBA'S COMPANY.
$200 MILLION IN SALES.
THE HONEST COMPANY.
-YES.
Herjavec:
IT'S ALL-NATURAL STUFF,
BECAUSE PEOPLE REALIZE
THE STUFF WE PUT ON OUR SKIN
COULD BE BAD FOR US.
SO THERE'S A TREND.
THE FACT YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY ONLINE SALES --
THAT'S A MARKET
YOU HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I WILL GIVE YOU THE $200,000.
I MEAN, YOU SAID
YOU WON'T DO IT FOR 50%,
JUST A LITTLE BIT LESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
FOR 45%.
I'M GONNA EDIT MY OFFER.
IT'S SUCH A STUPID
BUSINESS THING I'M GONNA DO.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU FOR 40%
ONLY $100,000 IN CASH,
ANOTHER $100,000 TO FUND
ANY OF YOUR PURCHASE ORDERS,
AND IF YOU DO
MORE PURCHASE ORDERS THAN THAT,
I'LL CONTINUE
TO FUND YOUR PURCHASE ORDERS.
HUGO, DEBRA, OUT OF NOWHERE,
OUT OF THIN AIR,
JUST WHEN WE THOUGHT
THE END WAS HERE,
YOU COME UP WITH TWO OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WE'D LOVE
TO TAKE YOUR OFFER, BARBARA.
-YES! SMART WOMAN.
-THANK YOU.
-AH, ROMANCE IN THE AIR.
-PLEASURE.
WHOO-HOO!
-WE'RE GONNA DO GREAT.
-ALL RIGHT, I HAVE NO DOUBT.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-NO DOUBT.
-THANK YOU, BARBARA.
-MY PLEASURE. TAKE CARE.
-SURE. GOD BLESS.
-VERY NICE TO MEET YOU.
GOODBYE.
-BYE-BYE. THANK YOU, GUYS.
-GOOD LUCK.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-CONGRATS.
-THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OH, MY GOD.
THEY'RE SO CUTE.
GETTING A DEAL TODAY
WAS CRITICAL FOR US,
AND WHEN I THOUGHT
ALL THE SHARKS WERE OUT,
I WAS SENDING TELEPATHIC
MESSAGES TO BARBARA,
SAYING, "BARBARA, I REALLY WANT
TO DO A DEAL WITH YOU,"
AND I THINK SHE HEARD ME.
[ LAUGHS ]
♪♪
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
NICK MORTON AND EVAN MENDELSOHN
MADE A DEAL WITH ROBERT HERJAVEC
FOR THEIR UGLY CHRISTMAS SWEATER
COMPANY, TIPSY ELVES.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU LEFT A
$175,000-A-YEAR JOB TO DO THIS,
BECAUSE THAT TELLS ME
YOU'RE ALL IN, MY FRIEND.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Morton:
MAKING A DEAL WITH ROBERT WAS
THE BEST THING FOR TIPSY ELVES.
WE RECENTLY MET WITH ROBERT
ON "BEYOND THE TANK,"
AND HE GAVE US
SOME REALLY VALUABLE ADVICE
ON THE DIRECTION
OF OUR COMPANY.
Mendelsohn: THIS WAS A NEW LINE
WE LAUNCHED LAST YEAR
CALLED KNIT KNACK, AND THEY SELL
AT A LOWER PRICE POINT.
I HATE IT. IF YOU'RE GONNA
GO HIGH-END, GO HIGH-END.
IF YOU'RE GONNA GO LOW-END,
GO LOW-END.
PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE
GET KILLED.
THIS IS OUR NEWEST
SKI SUIT SAMPLE.
I'M SO EXCITED
FOR THESE.
Mendelsohn:
WE TOOK ROBERT'S ADVICE
AND FOCUSED OUR ENERGY
ON CREATING UNIQUE,
HIGH-QUALITY DESIGNS,
AND THAT'S
REALLY PAID OFF.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $800,000 IN SALES.
IN THE TWO YEARS
SINCE MAKING OUR DEAL,
WE'VE DONE
OVER $10 MILLION IN SALES.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
EIGHT WEEKS TILL CHRISTMAS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT'S EXCITING TIMES
FOR TIPSY ELVES.
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS, WE MOVED
INTO A SPACIOUS OFFICE,
AND WE'VE GONE FROM ONE EMPLOYEE
TO OVER 20.
LOOK WHAT JUST CAME IN.
ARE THOSE
THE MOVIE SWEATERS?
ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE MOST EXCITED ABOUT
IS THE FILMMAKERS FROM
THE UPCOMING HOLIDAY MOVIE,
"THE NIGHT BEFORE,"
APPROACHED US WITH AN OFFER
TO MANUFACTURE AND SELL
THE THREE SWEATERS WORN
BY THE LEAD ACTORS
IN THE FILM.
WE'RE PROJECTING
THAT WE'RE GONNA SELL
OVER $2 MILLION WORTH
OF THESE SWEATERS.
GOT SOME NEW THANKSGIVING
DESIGNS I JUST WORKED UP.
-NICE.
-AWESOME.
Morton: WHEN WE STARTED
TIPSY ELVES, WE NEVER EXPECTED
TO BE SELLING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF CHRISTMAS SWEATERS.
IT'S ALLOWED BOTH EVAN AND I
TO QUIT OUR JOBS.
IT'S ALLOWED US
TO PARTNER WITH ROBERT,
WHO'S BEEN
AN UNBELIEVABLE MENTOR,
AND WE COME TO WORK EVERY DAY,
AND WE COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED.
All: HAPPY HOLIDAYS!
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A SOLUTION
FOR OUR BUSY MODERN LIVES.
♪♪
HI. MY NAME IS ARTHUR.
AND I'M RYAN. AND WE'RE
THE CO-FOUNDERS OF CLEAN CUBE.
WE'RE ASKING FOR $300,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, WE LIVE
IN A WORLD OF CONVENIENCE.
TODAY, PEOPLE ARE ORDERING
THEIR TOILET PAPER
AND TOOTHPASTE ONLINE.
YOU CAN EVEN GET
YOUR CLOTHES LAUNDERED
WITH A SIMPLE PHONE APP.
BUT PEOPLE
ARE STILL STRUGGLING
WITH THE FINAL LEG
OF THESE TRANSACTIONS --
THE ACTUAL HAND-OFF
BETWEEN THE DELIVERY PERSON
AND THE CUSTOMER.
WHEN YOU ORDER SOMETHING ONLINE,
YOU HAVE TO SIT THERE
AND SUFFER THROUGH
A TWO-HOUR DELIVERY WINDOW,
OR A PACKAGE CAN GET LEFT
VULNERABLE ON YOUR DOORSTEP.
EVEN WORSE,
YOU MISS IT ALL TOGETHER,
AND IT GETS TAKEN BACK
TO THE DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
IN THE INDUSTRY, WE CALL THIS
THE PROBLEM OF THE LAST MILE.
CLEAN CUBE
HAS A SOLUTION.
CLEAN CUBE IS
LIKE A DIGITAL DOORMAN.
WE ARE THE MISSING LINK
BETWEEN CONSUMERS
AND THE ON-DEMAND
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
NOW, WE BROUGHT
A REPLICA OF ONE
OF OUR CURRENT INSTALLATIONS
IN NEW YORK CITY,
AND WE WOULD LOVE THE CHANCE
TO DEMO THE TECHNOLOGY FOR YOU.
BARBARA,
WOULD YOU MIND COMING UP?
WHY NOT?
-HI, BARBARA.
-HI.
THANKS
FOR HELPING US OUT.
SO, BARBARA,
YOU'RE A NEW YORKER.
YES,
WITH A DOORMAN.
ONCE YOU REGISTER,
YOU GET A PASSCODE.
SO YOUR PASSCODE
FOR THE DEMO IS 12345.
MM-HMM.
SO WHY DON'T YOU DROP OFF
THE DRY CLEANING?
-OKAY.
-SO PRESS THE START BUTTON.
-YEAH.
-PUT IN YOUR PASSCODE.
12345.
AND THEN DROP OFF
YOUR DRY CLEANING.
IT'S SHOWING YOU
WHICH CUBES ARE AVAILABLE.
SO, RIGHT NOW, ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS PRESS THE WHITE CUBE,
AND IT'LL POP OPEN.
[ CLICK ]
SO OPEN THE CUBE.
AND STICK IT IN.
AND HIT "DONE."
NOT BAD.
WELL, IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU ALSO HAVE A PICK UP.
[ GASPS ]
YES.
SO, JUST PRESS
THE PICK UP BUTTON.
YEP.
AND IT SHOWS YOU
WHAT YOU HAVE TO PICK UP.
SO PRESS THE GREEN BUTTON.
-MM-HMM.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE YOUR PICK UP
IS IN THIS CUBE.
[ CLICK ]
POP IT OPEN.
A SURPRISE PACKAGE.
I LIKE IT.
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
OOH.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S THE PACKAGE
YOU ORDERED FOR MARK.
[ THUD ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
-THERE YOU GO, FOR MARK.
-YOU DELIVER IT.
I'M NOT CARRYING HIS STUFF.
-OH, SURE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE YOU GO, MARK.
THANK YOU.
WHAT IS IT, BY THE WAY?
Shmulevsky:
SO WE KNOW YOU'RE --
YOU HAVE THE THREE COMMAS
FOR BILLIONAIRE.
WE THOUGHT
WE WOULD UP IT ONE --
THE TRILLIONAIRE HAT.
-THERE YOU GO.
-WHOA.
-NOW, SHARKS.
WE HAVE A SOLID FOOTPRINT
IN NEW YORK CITY,
AND NOW WE NEED YOUR EXPERTISE
TO GROW AND SCALE OUR PLATFORM.
WHERE ARE YOU
INSTALLING THESE?
WHY ARE THEY GIVING YOU
THE REAL ESTATE FOR THEM?
WHAT ARE THE ECONOMICS
FOR THEM AND FOR YOU?
SURE. SO WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
40 LOCATIONS IN NEW YORK CITY.
40?
YEAH, UH, IN THE
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS.
UH, OUR BIGGEST BUILDING
IS 168 UNITS,
AND OUR SMALLEST IS 10.
-SO, HOW MANY CUBES --
SO THESE ARE
NON-DOORMAN BUILDINGS
THAT WANT
DOORMAN-TYPE SERVICES?
-EXACTLY.
-AND HOW MANY CUBES IS IT?
SO WE'RE AMENITIZING
THE BUILDINGS.
SO, THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION.
THE BEST PART ABOUT THESE
IS THEY'RE COMPLETELY MODULAR
AND LEGO-LIKE.
PER 100 TENANTS,
HOW MANY CUBES DO YOU NEED?
BECAUSE NOTHING
WOULD MAKE ME CRAZIER
THAN BRINGING DOWN MY LAUNDRY
FROM THE 58th FLOOR...
-AND NOT HAVING A CUBE.
-...AND NOT HAVING A CUBE OPEN.
SURE.
I WOULD PERSONALLY FIND YOU
IF THAT HAPPENED.
SO, UH, RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE AVERAGING
ABOUT, UH, SEVEN APARTMENTS
FOR ONE CUBE.
AND WHAT IS THE CAPITAL COST
FOR ALL OF IT TOGETHER?
SO, A TYPICAL INSTALLATION
IS ABOUT $3,000.
THE FIGHT SEEMS TO BE,
YOU GO INTO A LARGE BUILDING,
SOMEBODY
IS MANAGING THE BUILDING
AND SAYS, "OKAY,
YOU WANT TO PUT THAT IN?
IT'S GONNA COST YOU
$400 A WEEK,
OR $1,000 A MONTH,"
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
IS THAT HOW IT WORKS?
SO, THE LAST THREE
INSTALLATIONS WE'VE DONE,
THE LANDLORD HAS PAID ABOUT
$7,000 PER INSTALLATION...
BUT -- BUT --
-WOW.
-THEY PAID YOU $7,000?
-WELL -- YES.
WELL, THE REASON
FOR IT IS BECAUSE --
WHY? WHAT'S THE BENEFIT
TO THE LANDLORD?
IT'S A HUGE SERVICE
TO HIS PEOPLE.
I MEAN, THERE'S NO --
THE RENT IN NEW YORK
IS ASTRONOMICAL,
AND THERE'S DEAD SPACE,
SO THE ABILITY
TO AMENITIZE
THESE LOBBIES --
AND THEN THEY RAISE THE RENT,
AND THAT'S IT.
YES.
OH, SO YOU THINK IT HELPS
THE BUILDING BE MORE ATTRACTIVE?
FOR SURE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
Greiner: FOR SURE.
BARBARA,
DO YOU FIND THAT'S TRUE?
IF A BUILDING
HAD THIS IN IT...
Corcoran: WELL, THE -- THE --
WOULD YOU PAY $7,000
AS A LANDLORD?
THE REASON A BUILDING
WITHOUT A DOORMAN
CAN'T COMMAND IN THE RENT
THAT THEY SHOULD --
SAME SQUARE FOOTAGE,
SAME VIEW, SAME AMENITIES --
BUT THEY CAN'T CHARGE
WHAT THEY WANT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
A DOORMAN.
SO THIS, IN A WAY,
REPLACES THE DOORMAN.
NOT TOTALLY,
BUT I GET IT.
AND OUR VISION
IS NOT JUST THAT THIS IS
A REAL-ESTATE PLAY
FOR RESIDENTIAL MARKETS.
WE WANT TO PEPPER THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH CLEAN CUBES.
WE WANT TO PUT THEM
IN ANY LOCATION
THAT OPENS EARLY
AND CLOSES LATE.
STARBUCKS, GYMS,
EVEN CHASE BANK ATMs.
SO IF I HAD A BROWNSTONE,
I'D WALK TO A LOCATION.
LAUNDROMATS. LAUNDROMATS.
OH, SO YOU'RE SAYING
YOU WANT TO PUT THEM ANYWHERE.
Shmulevsky: EXACTLY.
BUT WHO WOULD PAY FOR THAT,
AND WHY?
IT'LL BE BETWEEN
THE SUBWAY STOP
AND YOUR --
AND YOUR APARTMENT.
AND HOW WOULD YOU MONETIZE THAT?
WHO WOULD PAY FOR IT THEN?
WE'RE -- WE WANT TO CHARGE A $10
ACCESS FEE TO THE SUBSCRIBER.
TELL ME
WHAT YOUR SALES ARE.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE NOT CHARGING
A SUBSCRIPTION FEE,
SO WE'RE ONLY MAKING MONEY
FROM THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE
AND FROM THE MARGINS.
SO THE LAST -- THE TRAILING
12 MONTH SALES HAS BEEN $130K,
WHICH $65,000, OR 50%, HAS COME
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
ARTHUR, HOW MANY USERS?
WE HAVE 528 --
552 USERS.
ARTHUR, I LOVE THIS SPACE.
I THINK THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
I KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING
TO INSTANT DELIVERY.
BUT WHAT I DON'T LIKE ABOUT IT
IS THE FOOTPRINT.
IN A WORLD THAT'S MOVING
TO FASTER SERVICES,
YOU NEED PHYSICAL SPACE.
YOU'VE GOT TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
TO USE IT,
AND YOU'VE GOT
TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
TO PUT IN A LARGE FOOTPRINT
INTO CONVENIENT NEIGHBORHOODS.
SURE.
I -- I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE
AN UPHILL BATTLE.
I DON'T SEE THIS WORKING.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, SO I LOOK AT IT
THIS WAY -- ANY DEAL I DO,
I TRY AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS THE POINT OF RESISTANCE
THAT STOPS IT FROM SCALING.
AND IN THIS CASE,
EVERY SINGLE INSTALLATION
IS A LONG,
PROTRACTED NEGOTIATION
WITH EITHER
THE INDEPENDENT STORE OWNER
IN A CONVENIENCE STORE,
THE LANDLORD,
THE OPERATOR.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF STUFF
HAS TO HAPPEN
BEFORE YOU
ACTUALLY INSTALL THESE.
BUT IT'S A HUGE PAIN
IN THE...REAR END --
LARGE PAIN THERE.
AND I HATE REAR-END PAIN.
I'M OUT.
I KNOW THERE IS
A HUGE PROBLEM THERE.
YOU HAVE THIS GREAT IDEA,
BUT YOU'RE STILL
FIGURING IT OUT --
JUST EVEN HOW TO MONETIZE IT.
YOU'RE JUST
AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I WOULD
WRAP MY ARMS AROUND THIS
AS A BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE IN THE RACE
BETWEEN THE QUALITY
OF THE SOFTWARE INTERFACE,
THE SERVICES YOU CAN OFFER,
THE -- THE PURE,
ON-DEMAND ECONOMY,
AND PEOPLE WHO WILL SEE
THIS MARKET
AND TRY TO CAPTURE
ALL OF THAT MARGIN THEMSELVES.
I JUST DON'T SEE
THE "WOW FACTOR" THAT --
THAT'S GONNA GIVE IT
A HOCKEY STICK,
AND, SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
-ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
-YOU'RE WELCOME.
OKAY, THAT LEAVES ME.
I THINK YOU HAVE
A TERRIFIC BUSINESS
FOR ONE APPLICATION ONLY.
I DON'T BELIEVE
THE SUBSCRIPTION METHOD
IS REALLY GONNA WORK
AT YOUR LOCAL 7-Eleven.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
BUT THERE'S A PROBLEM
IN NEW YORK
FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE DOORMEN.
BUT HERE'S HOW THE REAL ESTATE
BREAKS DOWN.
YOU HAVE THOSE BUILDINGS THAT
HAVE IN EXCESS OF 100 UNITS --
THEY ALL HAVE DOORMEN,
ALL RIGHT?
99% OF THEM.
THEN YOU HAVE THE BUILDINGS
THAT HAVE FEWER
THAN EIGHT UNITS,
AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SPACE FOR THIS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE SWEET SPOT
THAT'S PERFECT FOR YOU --
THE UNITS
THAT HAVE 60, 80, 100 UNITS,
AND THEY DON'T HAVE DOORMEN --
THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR IT.
AND THEY COULD GET MORE
FOR THEIR RENT
IF THEY HAVE THIS
IN THERE, OKAY?
FOR SURE.
BUT THAT'S
ONLY ONE LITTLE THING.
YOU'RE TRYING TO STICK
THAT THREAD
THROUGH THAT LITTLE NEEDLE EYE,
AND THAT'S IT.
I THINK THERE'S A NEED FOR IT,
BUT I DON'T SEE IT
AS A BIG PLAY.
I JUST DON'T SEE YOU MAKING
A LOT OF MONEY ON THIS THING.
IT DOESN'T GET ME EXCITED,
I'M SORRY TO SAY, SO I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU.
-OKAY.
-THANK YOU, SHARKS.
-THANK YOU, GUYS.
-PLEASURE.
GOOD LUCK WITH THIS.
GOOD IDEA.
-NICE MEETING YOU.
-UH-HUH.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT
TO HAVE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH, YOU KNOW,
MARK OR BARBARA,
AND, YOU KNOW,
GROW THIS BUSINESS
THE WAY WE SEE IT
AND HOW WE WANT IT.
AND IT WOULD HAVE SHOT US
OUT OF THE BARREL,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE -- WE'RE, UH --
WE'LL DO IT ON OUR OWN.
[ CHUCKLES ]
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A FUN AND CONVENIENT WAY
TO STAY FIT.
♪♪
HI. MY NAME IS GLORIA HOFFMAN,
AND THIS IS MY AMAZING MOTHER.
HI. I'M LINDA CLARK,
AND WE'RE THE CO-OWNERS
AND CO-DEVELOPERS
OF THE SIMPLY FIT BOARD.
WE'RE HERE ASKING
FOR $125,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15%
OF OUR BUSINESS.
NOW, WHETHER WE WANT
TO ADMIT IT OR NOT,
WE ALL HAVE PROBLEM AREAS,
FROM THE BELLY FAT
TO THE SADDLEBAGS,
THOSE DREADED MUFFIN TOPS.
YOU KNOW, THE SIX-PACKS
THAT WE ONCE HAD
HAVE NOW SADLY TURNED
INTO KEGS,
BUT WE'RE BATTLING THE BULGE
WITH ONE SIMPLE PRODUCT.
Together: INTRODUCING
THE SIMPLY FIT BOARD.
NOW, WE'VE COMBINED CARDIO
TO BURN OFF THE FAT
WHILE BUILDING MUSCLES AND CORE
STRENGTH AT THE SAME TIME.
JUST STANDING ON THE BOARD,
YOU'RE STRENGTHENING
YOUR CORE, YOUR BACK.
YOU'RE TONING YOUR LEGS, AND
YOU'RE IMPROVING YOUR BALANCE.
BUT LET'S FACE IT --
I WANT A SLIMMER WAISTLINE,
BUT AT MY AGE,
BALANCE IS JUST AS IMPORTANT.
WE CALL THIS
A BALANCE BOARD WITH A TWIST,
BECAUSE WE DEVELOPED IT
USING A SPECIAL PLASTIC
THAT HAS A HIGH LEVEL
OF LUBRICATION IN IT
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO TWIST
AT THE SAME TIME.
NOW, TWISTING
NOT ONLY WORKS UP
YOUR HEART RATE
TO BURN OFF THE FAT,
BUT IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY
EXERCISES YOU CAN DO
THAT WORKS EVERY SINGLE MUSCLE
IN YOUR CORE.
NOW, THERE ARE LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF EXERCISES
THAT YOU CAN DO
ON THE BOARD.
OBVIOUSLY,
THE BASIC TWIST,
BUT YOU CAN ALSO DO SQUATS,
PUSH-UPS, AND EVEN PLANKS.
EVERYONE
CAN BE SIMPLY FIT.
SO, WHICH ONE
OF YOU SHARKS WANTS
TO LOSE THAT MUFFIN TOP
AND GAIN SOME DOUGH?
I WANT TO TRY IT, EVEN THOUGH --
COME ON DOWN.
I WANT TO TRY IT,
EVEN THOUGH...
WE WANT YOU GUYS
TO COME TRY THESE.
...I HAVE
AN ADONIS-LIKE FIGURE.
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT.
HE HAS A BIG MUFFIN TOP.
NOT THAT ANY OF YOU
HAVE MUFFIN TOPS.
Clark: JUST PUT
YOUR FEET ON ONE SIDE...
YEAH, I'LL TRY. YEAH.
...AND THEN ON THE SAME SPOT
ON THE OTHER SIDE,
AND YOU'RE GONNA BALANCE
ON THAT CENTER POINT.
YEAH.
I'M GETTING
A LITTLE FARTHER ADVANCED.
-OKAY, GET THEM SET.
-OH, YOU'RE IN YOUR SOCKS.
-OH, MARK.
-YOU NEED YOUR TENNIS SHOES ON.
I NEED TENNIS SHOES?
I DON'T HAVE TENNIS --
-OH, MY GOD.
-GO GET YOUR SHOES ON.
YOU'RE DOING IT WRONG.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THESE.
THESE MIGHT HELP YOU.
THE MORE YOU GET
THE BOARD TWISTING,
THE MORE YOU'RE GONNA FEEL IT
IN YOUR BACK AND YOUR WAISTLINE.
THESE CAN -- JUST HOLD THEM
STRAIGHT AT YOUR SIDE.
YOU LOOK LIKE
TWO OLD MEN OUT THERE.
OH, MY GOD!
-IS IT HARD TO BALANCE?
-WE HAVE A GUIDE, TOO.
NO, IT'S NOT HARD TO
BALANCE -- YOU JUST SLIDE
IF YOU HAVE YOUR SOCKS ON.
YEAH, YOU'VE --
YOU'VE GOT YOUR SOCKS ON.
I GUESS WE CAN'T DO IT
IN OUR HEELS, CAN WE?
Hoffman: YOU SEE
HOW EASY IT MOVES, THOUGH?
THERE YOU GO!
[ LAUGHS ]
-OH, YOU LITTLE SHOWOFF.
-WATCH OUT.
BUT WHEN YOU GET COMFORTABLE
WITH IT AND YOU GET IT GOING,
IT REALLY, REALLY WORKS UP
THAT HEART RATE.
GOING LIKE A PRO.
-OH, LOOK AT YOU GO.
-MY FEET SLIDE.
-IT'S NOT THAT HARD.
-YOU'RE PRETTY GOOD AT IT.
LINDA, I'M GETTING DIZZY!
STOP THAT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, TELL US,
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THIS?
WELL, WHEN I TURNED 60
A FEW YEARS AGO, I --
ALL OF A SUDDEN, I COULDN'T LOSE
ANY WEIGHT AROUND MY MIDDLE.
AND I'VE HAD FOUR KIDS AND I'M
KIND OF VERTICALLY CHALLENGED
AND LIKE TO EAT.
SO, ONE DAY, I WAS PLAYING OUT
WITH MY GRANDKIDS
ON A SKATEBOARD TOY,
AND I THOUGHT, "MAN,
THIS IS HITTING ME
IN ALL THE RIGHT SPOTS."
I CALLED GLORIA.
WE DID SOME RESEARCH.
WE BRAINSTORMED,
AND THE LIGHT CAME ON,
AND VOILà --
THE SIMPLY FIT BOARD.
O'Leary:
BUT, GLORIA, HOW DOES IT WORK
ON A TYPICAL CARPET
IN SOMEONE'S DEN?
YOU KNOW, IT WORKS
ON ALMOST EVERY --
IT WORKS ON ALL CARPETS.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE --
WHAT HAPPENS IF IT'S
ON THE WOOD SURFACE?
WE DON'T WANT YOU
TO SCRATCH YOUR WOOD FLOORS,
SO WE DO RECOMMEND
PUTTING SOMETHING DOWN, BUT --
-DO YOU SELL THE MATS, TOO?
-WE DON'T.
WE ACTUALLY
JUST HAVE A PROTOTYPE
MADE OF A PLATFORM
THAT WE'RE GONNA GET MADE,
AND SO THIS IS
ACTUALLY CURVED
SO THAT THEY START
IN THE MIDDLE.
IF THEY MOVE FORWARD A LITTLE,
IT AUTOMATICALLY ADJUSTS
THEM BACK.
CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON THIS?
OUR SYSTEM IS PATENTED,
SO --
-WHAT IS THE SYSTEM?
-WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THE BOARD
WITH THE PLATFORM.
STANDING THE WAY
YOU ARE RIGHT THERE,
LINDA,
THERE'S NO PATENT ON THAT?
-NO.
ONCE I PUT IT
ON THE SPECIAL PLATFORM --
YES.
-SO IT'S THE ATTACHMENT?
-YES, YES.
O'Leary: SO SOMEONE COULD
KNOCK IT OFF SLIGHTLY
AND DO THE SAME THING --
THAT'S THE RISK.
Corcoran: EASILY.
OR THEY COULD JUST COPY IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PATENT, KEVIN.
WELL, WHEN YOU HAVE
A PRODUCT LIKE THAT,
WHAT YOU WANT IS YOU WANT TO GET
OUT TO MARKET VERY QUICKLY.
EXACTLY.
SO TELL US
HOW MANY SALES YOU HAVE.
YEAH, AND -- AND WE LAUNCHED
ABOUT 18 MONTHS AGO.
WE HAVE SOLD OVER 15,700 BOARDS,
GROSSED $575,000.
-GOOD FOR YOU.
-HOW MUCH DOES THE BOARD COST?
$45 RETAIL ONLINE.
SO IT COSTS YOU
HOW MUCH TO MAKE?
$9.87.
-WOW!
-YEAH.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE CHEAPEST
BALANCE BOARD ON THE MARKET.
AND DO YOU SELL IT --
DO YOU SELL IT --
YOU SELL IT THROUGH RETAIL?
WE SELL IT
AT CONSUMER SHOWS, MAINLY,
AND THEN ONLINE ON OUR WEBSITE.
GLORIA, ON THE $500,000 YOU
SOLD, WHAT DID YOU MAKE ON THAT?
$260,000.
ARE THERE OTHER
BALANCE BOARDS ON THE MARKET,
AND IF THERE ARE,
WHAT ARE THEY LIKE?
I JUST MET WITH
A LARGE SPORTING GOODS STORE,
AND SHE SAID, "I'M PITCHED
BALANCE BOARDS ALL THE TIME.
THEY ALL LOOK THE SAME."
AND THEY'RE BASICALLY
A WOODEN PLANK
WITH A CYLINDER UNDERNEATH.
SHE LOVED THE PRODUCT.
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO SAID,
"WE GET PITCHED ALL THE TIME
ON BALANCE BOARDS.
YOURS LOOKS SO DIFFERENT."
LOOK, THE ISSUE ISN'T,
CAN YOU BE COPIED?
YOU WILL BE COPIED.
-YES.
-RIGHT.
-THE ISSUE IS HOW BIG CAN YOU BE
DESPITE IT?
-YEAH, YES.
O'Leary: EXACTLY.
IT'S NOT GONNA JUST BE
A ONE-PRODUCT SHOW.
GUYS, I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
NEED MORE MONEY FOR INVENTORY,
SO I'M GONNA
STEP IT UP A NOTCH HERE.
I WANT TO DO THIS DEAL WITH YOU.
I LIKE IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000
FOR 30%.
I RARELY GIVE YOU MORE
THAN YOU WANT
AT EXACTLY THE VALUATION.
YOU'RE CHANGING YOUR EVIL WAYS.
...BUT I KIND OF BELIEVE THAT,
BECAUSE OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE,
THAT THIS PRODUCT IS GONNA
FIND A NICHE IN PEOPLE OVER 40.
SO I'M BETTING ON YOU BIG.
I THINK HALF OF THE DOLLARS
I'M GIVING YOU HAS TO GO
IN INVENTORY.
I REALLY DO.
GLORIA, LET ME TELL YOU WHERE
I'M AT -- FANTASTIC PRODUCT.
MY CONCERN IS THERE'S
NOTHING PROPRIETARY HERE.
UM, GREAT IDEA, THOUGH.
I WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.
I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
JUST -- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER OFFERS?
THIS IS DEFINITELY A PRODUCT
THAT NEEDS AN INFOMERCIAL,
AND I'VE HAD BAD EXPERIENCE
WITH INFOMERCIALS
ON THESE KINDS OF PRODUCTS,
SO FOR ME, I'M OUT.
Cuban:
GUYS, I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
BUT THE NETWORK
MARKETING-TYPE APPROACH
REALLY ISN'T MY STRENGTH,
SO WHILE I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A GREAT PRODUCT,
I DON'T THINK I'M THE BEST
PERSON TO TAKE IT THERE,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
THIS OBVIOUSLY IS
RIGHT UP MY ALLEY.
YOU KNOW
I'M THE QUEEN OF QVC.
I'M THE KING.
HE'S THE JOKER OF QVC.
THE KING OF QVC.
-I LIKE YOU BOTH.
-HE JUST WANTS TO BE THE KING.
THE INFOMERCIAL WORLD
IS ALSO RIGHT UP MY ALLEY.
IT'S SOMETHING I'VE DONE
FOR 18 YEARS, AS WELL.
WE'D HAVE TO WORK REALLY HARD
AND QUICKLY,
BECAUSE,
TO EVERYBODY'S POINT,
THERE'S NOTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT IT.
SO HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
$125,000 AT 20%.
-THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
-NOT ENOUGH CASH.
NOT ENOUGH CASH.
IF THERE'S MONEY
THAT'S NEEDED,
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY
TO FUND PURCHASE ORDERS.
IT MEANS IT'S WORKING.
SO AS MUCH AS WE GET IN
IN ORDERS
IS AS MUCH AS I WILL HELP
TO BANKROLL.
IT'S TIME
TO MAKE A DECISION.
I'M JUST WONDERING,
BASED ON OUR BACKGROUNDS...
WELL, I'M CURIOUS
IF THEY WOULD --
...WHAT YOU HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT.
♪♪
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
LORI AND KEVIN
HAVE COMPETING OFFERS
FOR GLORIA AND LINDA'S
EXERCISE BOARD, SIMPLY FIT.
ALL RIGHT, GLORIA, YOU'VE GOT
$125,000 FOR 20% FROM LORI,
$250,000 FOR 30%
FROM KEVIN.
DOWN TO TWO OFFERS.
-YOU GUYS HAVE TO GO FAST.
I'M JUST WONDERING,
BASED ON OUR BACKGROUNDS...
WELL, I'M CURIOUS
IF THEY WOULD --
...WHAT YOU HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT.
DO YOU WANT TO --
WOULD YOU GUYS WANT
TO DO A DEAL TOGETHER?
THE QUESTION IS,
HOW MUCH EQUITY --
NO.
I WILL GO SOLO HERE,
BECAUSE THIS IS MY WORLD.
YES.
THIS IS --
THIS IS MY SWEET SPOT.
THIS IS WHAT
I'M EXCELLENT AT.
I MAKE MILLIONAIRES THIS WAY.
IT'S WHAT I DO,
AND I TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
BUT I DON'T NEED A PARTNER.
GUYS, ANY SHARK CAN GET
YOU INTO ANY RETAILER.
WE'VE ALL DONE DEALS AROUND
EVERY KIND OF PRODUCT CATEGORY.
YOU SHOULD TALK
TO MY ENTREPRENEURS,
ALL WOMEN, THAT HAVE MADE
A FORTUNE WITH ME.
OH, GOOD LORD.
WE LOVE ALL OF YOU GUYS,
AND COMING IN, OF COURSE,
WE THOUGHT QVC WOULD BE
AN INCREDIBLE OUTLET.
IT WILL BE.
WOULD YOU DO 18%?
DO YOU REALLY THINK
IT MATTERS
FOR THAT LITTLE BIT
OF DIFFERENCE?
SHE ASKED FOR 20%, RIGHT?
I'M JUST ASKING.
I ASKED FOR 20%.
I THINK IT'S FAIR.
[ BOTH WHISPERING INDISTINCTLY ]
♪♪
IT'S TIME TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
KEVIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR OFFER.
NO PROBLEM.
BUT, LORI, WE WOULD LOVE
TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
-WHOO!
-GOOD.
-THANK YOU.
-ALL RIGHT!
-YAY.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU TWO ARE
SMART LADIES.
Hoffman: YAY!
YOU'VE JUST CHOSEN
THE BEAUTY OVER THE BEAST.
YOU HAVE GREAT TASTE.
OH, I WOULDN'T CALL HIM
A BEAST.
-THANKS, BARB.
-I'M TELLING YOU SERIOUSLY.
-I-I-I LOVE YOU GUYS.
-THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU. THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-CONGRATULATIONS, LADIES.
-CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
-OH, MY GOD!
-YAY!
Hoffman:
WE LOVE MR. WONDERFUL, BUT LORI
WAS THE ONE TO GO WITH TODAY.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY GONNA
GET AMERICA TWISTING.
WHOO!
BRINGING FUN BACK TO FITNESS.
TWIST IN FRONT OF YOUR TV.
WITH THE SIMPLY FIT BOARD,
OF COURSE!